[Music]
easy
[Music]
viewer discretion is advised bad girls
[Music]
[Music]
feminist cops is filmed on location with
the brave strong women of law
enforcement all suspects are innocent
until proven guilty in a court of law
315 confirmed suspect is in 302 over all
right so we got two warrants out for
this guy's arrest and he's not coming
out so we're gonna have to extract them
[Music]
uh
um
315 correction suspect is in 301 over
bad girls bad girls what you gonna do
what you gonna do when did they go for
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stranger
[Music]
hmm
wow that tastes delicious
and it tastes delicious because i'm not
a sociopath so i can enjoy things we'll
be talking about amber heard quite a bit
today uh right now is she not on the
stand okay she's not on the stand
exactly right now are they in recess so
i think so this is one a lot of you have
asked us to discuss uh amber heard a
little bit more uh and many of you say
that you don't want to see her face her
her horrible her pretty but horrible
evil face here's why we're going to be
doing uh quite a bit of live streaming
on amber heard later we're gonna get to
joe biden first former vice president
joe biden and him referring to you as
extremists right everyone who's pro-life
everyone who actually supports the idea
of abortion rights going back to the
states uh which brings my question to
the day before amber heard we'll have
some more questions later is who do you
think is the most extreme political
group in the united states is it far
right is it far left
is it far libertarian who
just want to smoke weed and trade
bitcoin on their couch i don't know the
point is we all have our thing
but uh i do think it's important this
amber this is kind of a landmark case
because i was very surprised to see that
the people uh least tolerant
of the shenanigans are women
particularly women who've been abused if
you run a search on amber heard and
abuse victims right now you will see
many abuse victims speaking out saying
that this does not seem to be someone
who is a victim of abuse and at the very
least we know she is an abuser as well
maybe amber heard was abused we don't
know it doesn't look like it but we
certainly know that she was an abuser
that was admitted yesterday
that she physically abused johnny depp
i'm not even a fan of johnny depp
but the guy had the crap kicked out of
him by a woman multiple times no one is
arguing that it's just did johnny depp
ever retaliate
that's a difficult standard to have in a
society and expecting uh
men and women to co-exist
again it's not do we have laws it's are
the laws applied equally and we know
they often aren't with hot chicks so
uh before we get to the rest of that uh
i don't know what's gonna happen if
they'll get us with copyright you'll
keep them posted right token on because
sometimes they do that if we get booted
here on youtube we're on rumble and
every monday through thursday eight
sorry eight every monday through
thursday 10 a.m eastern uh rumble or mug
club we'll go to mug club and take your
chats here today and do a little bit
more live streaming of amber heard
they're telling me we're going to play a
drinking game as we live stream i
it's early but it's cinco de mayo
relapse yep there you go well you just
had something in a plastic baggy was
that a please tell me it was a mint uh
it's a mustache okay i nix it and it's
off my face now and i'm not happy about
it it was it an accident yeah all right
i didn't introduce him hold on let me
get to you but because first we have to
introduce the star uh gerald a is not
here he's uh just had a child so gerald
b how are you
you know what i never thought i'd say it
i missed gerald a little bit i really do
yeah i gotta be honest uh gerald b i
don't mean to offend you just not as
good no gerald he just takes it that's
the problem you know the whipping
there's a difference between being a
whipping post being a good sport like
gerald a yeah and just jlb almost seems
to enjoy it almost seems to avail
himself to whatever it is you want to
provide it really just gives it well no
he doesn't give anything but he does
receive he takes yes you know what it
feels good to give gerald b
don't just be a taker
we'll get you all day back in yeah in
one day yeah uh by the way uh you hear
this voice you know he was the quickest
wit uh quickest wit in the west he'll be
in uh springfield missouri lincoln
nebraska this week and you can go to
lightweight.com
tour to book tickets dave landau how are
you sir ahoy good good enough
obviously i'm team depp um yeah i i i
see i'm thought of touch i thought we
were still werewolf or vampire is that
not yes
i i nicked my mustache last night i'm
very upset so now i got to regrow it
from scratch yeah i'm regrowing it or
leave in the comments if you think i
should or shouldn't yeah i i think the
comments shouldn't shouldn't yeah i
liked it did your wife like it
uh yeah really
i guess i don't well okay that means
there wasn't a conversation well it's
more just like i'll live with that yes
exactly i mean maybe right that's well
that's what most wives do they just i
looked up tom selleck and bert reynolds
without a mustache yesterday and it's
like it's just no not okay don't even
try and search that with wilford brimley
it's just a lemon party now doesn't make
sense don't search lemon party don't
search wilfred ripley none of us is good
so before we move on here to uh
former vice president joe biden
let me show you what happened yesterday
and this is the moment this is the
moment yesterday amber heard was
testifying she's testifying today and i
think it's an important character study
in a sociopath we might even want to
bring in kevin later who's a a phd
candidate in psychology
i'm a sociopath
or at least a narcissist
yesterday she said something that i
think was maybe lost on most people
and it shocked me when i heard it and i
think it's the primary problem with
third wave feminism and condemning men
for toxic masculinity and wanting it
both ways
see if you can catch
the the terrifying part
before i know it he
starts crying
now and you know like i i
have never seen
an adult man cry
i didn't really see my dad cry at my
grandma's funeral you know just it's
weird
and he's crying
it's weird
so hold on let me get this straight
on the stand while you're crying well
there's no self-awareness she's trying
to emulate right what she has seen is
human emotions right now yeah and she
doesn't realize that you shouldn't say a
man crying is weird so let's be let me
be clear about this we say toxic
masculinity you shouldn't be aggressive
you shouldn't be uh you shouldn't be a
type a personality you shouldn't take
control you shouldn't exhibit
necessarily leadership qualities these
are bad things this is toxic masculinity
open with your emotions okay then if you
cry it's weird
if you yell it's abuse if you had a
cabinet it's abuse if you cry it's weird
what is someone like johnny depp
supposed to what is the man in your life
supposed to do i know not all women feel
this way but there are a lot of women
who use it against them
come on all of us have had a woman use
it against you when you cry
you've been i remember being in a
relationship where they said you know
you shouldn't yell you shouldn't get mad
that's disguising your emotions
vulnerability is and then i cried and
they were like [ __ ] i was like i can't
believe this
well it's not my fault it just happens
during sex yes usually after
usually her daring after before and then
i just cry because i'm wondering why it
always happens i'm vexed and i just
can't figure it out so what is the guy
supposed to cry so this is why men don't
cry it's not because men don't think
it's acceptable to cry i've always there
are acceptable times to cry you can't
cry all the time you can't be a cry baby
mostly unacceptable mostly unacceptable
but certainly not in the realm of a
relationship or a death in the family in
other words it shouldn't be weird for a
man to cry but if a man cries it's used
against him we also tell men hey get
help don't be afraid to get help go and
get help it's brave to take that step
unless you have someone who wants to
take half your stuff like amber heard in
which case any help that you've ever
sought out is now in the now on display
for the whole world to see
right your your your doctor patient
confidentiality goes away in a civil
case with a divorce if a woman is trying
to use it against you so what is so what
johnny if johnny depp wanted to protect
himself rather than do what is expected
of him in today's anti-masculine society
is
not get help
so there's no record of it just say
there's nothing wrong with me and never
cry and keep it bottled up and then die
much younger than women that's why life
expectancy is uh what it is
that's what he should have done if he
wanted to protect himself this we need
to pick a lane and that's why beers for
men yes
except for uh
well the bruce willis did those wine
cooler commercials yeah that's true he
did yeah well and look what happened to
him it's true he needs an earpiece
because he can't even remember where he
is pours orange juice into cereal now
before we go to uh amber herd
i've done that
put orange juice in here i've done that
i've done that and i've had to use water
but that had nothing to do with
confusion no i just didn't have no milk
this and captain do you have a cabin
crunch dry
well it's not dry if there's water no
but i mean if you if you haven't done if
you don't use water if you don't use
water you gotta use water yeah
right yeah it's it's like sandpaper oh
yeah you might as well be eating bullets
yes
i mean they still taste good i don't
know bullets taste did you know you can
season meat with gunpowder i don't know
i'd one day i'd like to find out how
both today's
i think we all would
certainly right now so
like in nebraska springfield missouri
pride my funeral
i don't want to be weird
imagine if you're sitting there crying
if you know dave tastes a taste of 380
and we're sitting there at his funeral
and if we start crying amber goes that's
weird yeah i remember when i was crying
uh at every funeral i always have like
an uncle come up to me and i was like
stop being so weird is that being weird
is this ridiculous come on now
you're a man you're carrying the family
name you're a step uncle the principal's
the same yeah when my son's grandfather
died he's like four i was like listen
stop being weird yeah it's ridiculous
well you know what he'll grow up to be a
better man well yeah you have to make
sure you bottle it up
and that's it that's it bottle it up and
don't let your wife know
that's what i do yep that's what men
lesson learned ladies you've made us
this way the amber herds of the world
boy boy and it's so and it's one isn't
it wonderful that this was the
ambassador for the me too movement there
you go we said chickens would come home
to roost here we are now speaking of
chickens coming home to roost i don't
know if you remember this we're going to
talk about uh biden's recent comments
about all of you being extremists so
i'll try and get through this relatively
quickly so we can get to amber heard
guys in the control room let me know
what she's doing how she's lying uh how
bad her acting is hopefully she gets a
razzy but joe former vice president joe
biden now is referring to all of you as
extremists for simply holding a view
that the majority of americans hold that
being said this is the playbook from the
left right they always play themselves
up to be captain unity they call for
civility
when they feel as though they're the
ones being under attack and then that
goes out the window once they don't get
their way like children or amber heard
or feminist but i repeat myself here we
go back to captain unity with the most
votes ever of any president wildly
popular 81 million let's see for all
those of you
who voted for president trump
i understand the disappointment tonight
i've lost a couple times myself but now
let's give each other a chance
it's time to put away the harsh rhetoric
lower the temperature
see each other again listen to each
other again
and to make progress we have to stop
treating our opponents as our enemies
they are not our enemies they are
americans
they're americans
well well that's nice it seems like he
really does want what's good for the
whole country well yeah no right i can
definitely see where the uh 81 million
votes came from but yeah um also you
have to remember he's a complete piece
of [ __ ] who calls his opponents
political extremists oh so it's a yin
and yang
right yep
for example uh it's one of those things
he's weird both things can be true
or in this case one is a lie
and one is true true right
who's on first not him he doesn't know
what first is he can't count to one
so here's an example of what he just
said about republicans uh i believe this
was yesterday you know to not vilify
your opponents they're americans this is
about a lot more than abortion the idea
that somehow
there is a inherent right
that there is no right of privacy that
there is no right and remember the
debate we you don't remember but we had
a debate about you don't remember
griswold versus connecticut there'd been
a law saying a married couple
could not purchase birth control in the
privacy of their own bedroom and use it
well that got struck down griswold
was thought to be a bad decision by bork
and i'm my guess is the guy's on the
supreme court now
what happens if you have a state changes
the law saying that that that children
who are lgbtq can't be in classrooms
with other children
is that legit under the way the decision
is written
what are the next things that are going
to be attacked
because this mega crowd is really the
most extreme political organization
that's existed in american history oh in
recent american history come on joe
there's good people on both sides you
would think so maggot what he means is
uh you know the half that devoted to you
know fewer votes in the most free and
fair election of all time who voted for
donald trump i guess they didn't learn
from the basket of deplorables
lgbtq kids won't be able to be in
schools no no just public school
teachers
but i don't understand even the woman
behind them is like is this oh gosh yeah
is this this is this is the leader of
the free world this is really what we're
doing uh for crying out loud can we
please just audit the voting machines no
okay does anyone smell [ __ ] so let me
ask you this well we're talking about
extremists on abortion look roe v wade
we've done a whole segment on this okay
we did a whole show on this if you don't
know the gas lighting works on me
where sometimes i have to go back and go
wait hold on
maybe i'm missing something because
every no no no no roe v wade being oh if
it were to be overturned which it likely
will just means that states can place
restrictions on abortions in the first
first trimester which they can't do
right now
and other states can not
it will allow states to do what they
want in abortion go yeah okay that's it
oh all right okay so you're lying but
there's the lying is i'm telling you it
works on me sometimes where i have to
second-guess myself that's why you make
all references available at
lightworkcredit.com you can click the
link in the description so let me ask
you this knowing the policy what is more
extreme you can take the left of course
you can take antifa you can take black
lives matter and then let's say you take
the january sixth
insurrectionist
okay you know what the scales of [ __ ]
i would still say they lean heavily in
one direction but let's look at abortion
right now let's look at the extremism
which he is accusing half the country of
being during the 2020 election okay
there were only two
democratic candidates two
who said they supported abortion
restrictions
after 24 weeks
that's six months
i don't know if we have that number uh
on uh the earliest born baby now but i'm
pretty sure it's right around that
number it's somewhere between 23 and 25
weeks
the argument of viability or whether
it's a life it doesn't matter to them
only two democrat candidates supported
abortion restrictions
in the in the third trimester
the fringe with the democrat is people
who don't believe in abortion up until
and including birth there are two out of
all democratic candidates it was 21
weeks and five days 21 weeks and five
days wow
dang and then i believe you should place
restrictions after 24 weeks just to keep
that in context because we're going to
come back to it what about uh uh hr 370
3755 which was uh i think was introduced
last year by judy choo
i don't choose
you
it would allow abortion up until birth
let me show you what the bill would have
been again while we're talking about
extremists
a prohibition on abortion after fetal
viability when
in the good faith medical judgment of
the treating healthcare provider
continuation of the pregnancy would pose
a risk to the pregnant patient's life or
health what this bill is saying is there
should be
no allowance for restrictions on
abortions even after viability
acknowledging viability you still can't
place any restrictions on it
up until birth i think that's pretty
extreme
i think it's more extreme than a
heartbeat bill
that's my opinion i would love to hear
the opinion of you if you're
particularly those who are pro-abortion
because i think dave has a very reasoned
view on it i don't agree with dave and i
don't agree on it but dave and i both
agree that up until including nine
months is
extreme that's the entire democratic
party except for
two people
seems a bit much
here's something else uh that is pretty
funny from the same bill this is what
they wrote they can't trip over their
own fake dicks the terms women and
women and women are used in this bill to
reflect the identity of the majority of
people targeted and affected by
restrictions on abortion services and to
address squarely the targeted
restrictions on abortion which are
rooted in misogyny however access to
abortion services is critical to the
health of every person capable of
becoming pregnant
so women
how that goes don't be up too steve oh
i'm sorry men and women yes anyone who
can hey did we get a fact check on this
as far as i know no man has been
has become pregnant and given birth i
don't know if there's a sixth day
science experiment uh i don't know if
you've seen the cartoon picture on your
phone
i well you know okay arnold doesn't
count and by the way danny devito was a
horribly absent father yeah he really
was
yeah see that that's what we put out
there they have to put this minute or i
drink something bubbly yes
they just they have to put in the bill
health of every person capable of
becoming pregnant so on one side you
have people saying yeah the maga
extremist all right give it over to the
states
and on the other side
you have all democrats except for two
saying abortion up until nine months and
including births for not just women but
any pregnant persons holy [ __ ] really
you don't get to use the extremist card
anymore you don't even get to use it for
the militiamen who are living in the
woods eating tree bark it's still not as
extreme it's not even close well you
can't win you can't not even not only
can you not win i shouldn't say that you
can't have a conversation because you
hit a dead end anywhere you go
so well what about the men that can get
pregnant it's like why are we are we was
that in roe v wade
did they bring that up in court well
what about uh
wade is a guy's name yeah huh what if
there was a wade who got pregnant is
there a way who got pregnant i'm just
saying what if i mean wade sounds like
wade does definitely not sound like the
name of a man who gets pregnant no it
doesn't no it doesn't the only less
pregnant male name would be wyatt yes
yeah that's not yeah there's it's too
manly no
it's a schuyler a skylar might skyler
might get pregnant pregnant man yeah
yeah you'd be like guys i'm not
surprised maybe like a gunner yeah
possibly unless he's like from sweden
but the point is
you know there are girly names
don't use girly names so carol carol now
not in the 70s is there a carol for men
oh carol o'connor
oh that's right it used to be an irish
name for men yeah okay now not so much
no no i can't imagine i mean if whoever
if you name your kid carol you might as
well name them please kick my ass now he
cites
griswold versus connecticut right that's
what led to kind of supreme court roe v
wade uh a lot of people have cited us we
have the references available look
he mentions the privacy issue of the con
constitution first let me clarify this
there is no right to privacy in the
constitution okay let's just be clear
about that now that's not saying that
you do not have the right to privacy in
certain instances that's not what i'm
arguing but for them to say abortion is
a constitutional right
because privacy is a constitutional when
neither one of them are
here's the thing
it's not a privacy issue when they want
to when you look at the bills that they
propose
so in other words right now they're
saying it's bad law the privacy argument
so that states cannot regulate abortion
right that's the argument from the right
for the left to say well the privacy
issue makes abortion a constitutional
right and by the way we acknowledge
viability like the bill i just told you
about from miss chu and you should still
be able to kill them anyway look you
don't have the right
okay let me give you an example of right
to privacy you have the right uh there's
patient doctor confidentiality right
same thing with lawyer client
confidentiality of course that goes out
the window if you know you have someone
who wants to take if amber wants to take
off your stuff then you have to be
fellate open for the world to see as
we're seeing right now but that goes
both ways there's an instance where you
have the right to privacy
the constitution doesn't have a broad
overreaching right to privacy that being
said you don't have the right to
privately murder somebody now i know not
everyone is pro-life and i understand
that however from their own bill they
have acknowledged that this is a person
because they've said no restrictions
after viability i don't think only via i
don't think viability is a valid
argument because a one and a half year
old an eight month old is
not viable it's just inside the womb
outside the womb you're just talking
about location difference at that point
at semantics but they've always argued
viability and now they have said
even at the point of viability
you have the right to terminate it you
don't have the right to privately commit
murder i do believe that aborting a six
seven eight month baby
is murder
but they do
so it doesn't matter what i say they do
that's a slippery slope remember how
back in the day i said it was a slippery
slope when we were talking about
same-sex marriage we were talking about
the idea that men and women were
fundamentally interchangeable regardless
of where you lined up on that
i just said it opens the door here
that we no longer have the roles of male
female in society that really men and
women are and now here we are
fundamentally interchangeable we said
hey look hold on a second you're just
talking about people identifying however
they want and they're
on their identification well what's
going to happen with sports they said
well ah a second that's just uh that's
it come on you're just fear monk well
here we are
if they say you have the right to
privacy as it applies to a crime like
murder like theft
where does that go
if they had their way it's a crappy
argument it's an extremist argument and
even worse your former vice president
most popular former vice president ever
goes into a humanities 101 logical
fallacy to make his point
and this one today
is uh is the red herring you guys can
run a search on this afterwards it's
very common logical fallacy it's where
you bring up something that's largely
irrelevant to try and take the argument
somewhere where you feel more
comfortable effectively
biden there is creating red herring by
saying what you may not remember this in
the clip he just said what about lgbtq
children they could be kicked out of
classrooms hold on wait
just so i'm clear that i'm understanding
this
if states have the right
to regulate abortion as they see fit in
their state meaning texas can have a
heartbeat bill in colorado can have an
abortion up until birth including birth
period and the federal government
doesn't have it under its jurisdiction
if that happens
gay boys won't be allowed in classrooms
yep
is there any way to follow this no
they're look of course they're clearly
protected under the equal protection
clause what do they mean though by gay
like gay kids aren't what
drag like children like well you know
they're the ones who put on the children
drag shows so that's nice
but i'm just wondering he's talking
about little kids right just to be clear
yes for everybody listening not
teenagers not these are about little
kids yeah the ones he likes yeah so the
one
there's not really like apple jacks he's
what he likes but it's not uh are they
really gay are they just silly at that
age yeah that's a good point you know
they sometimes they're just little
feminine all little kids say gay stuff
they're asexual yes when i was a young
kid they asked me what i wanted to be
when i grew up and because i saw that my
mom and dad lived together and i roomed
with my brother and then i saw teenagers
didn't room together anymore i was like
well i really like being his roommate i
want to be his roommate forever so i
said when i grow up i want to be a woman
so i can marry jordan and share the same
room forever well yeah and now they'd be
like well we're going to make that
happen right i mean my mom did my mom
did put me on birth control so she was
an early adopter well of course i've
been wearing a
i'm wearing the birth control patch
since i was six she told me they were
smarties
fun fact smarties as you know them here
in the united states uh in canada
smarties are just like a generic eminem
what you know as smarties a little like
kind of sugar tarts they're known as
rockets
in canada and can it's a silly place
what's wrong with you guys oh there's a
lot wrong with us have you seen our
black face prime minister and the queen
in our mind well i've seen that so yes
have you seen our military i've seen
your gold coins yes that you're supposed
to somehow give to a stripper yeah
loonies and toonies are very very they
have to wear diapers that's true toonies
are silly yeah they are that's it that's
a two dollar one we're the only we're
the only country canada we have the
looney which is a single dollar coin and
it's because there's a loon the bird on
the looney that's what they called it
then they created a two dollar coin
which looks like a giant peso and they
said what do we call it i know the
toonie we're a country so silly that our
currency is a pun
it also is loony toony yes i know it's
how did that make it through any kind of
legislature that's perfect that's
exactly what we need to put us back on
the map god save the queen people think
we're nothing more than america's hat
we'll show them with our plays onward
slash currency
it's the toonie standard this is great
here
so look lgbt children going back to buy
they're clearly protected under the
equal protection clause let me read this
from you no state shall make or enforce
any law which will abridge the
privileges or immunities of citizens of
the united states this has nothing to do
with the due process clause here's
something else that i want to move on to
really quickly because amber heard isn't
on but there's another person olivia
wilde who is newton john
olivia newton jonas
she was she was she was hot she was
quite the dish
yeah am i allowed to say that is that
toxic masculinity it's actually can we
all say that olivia newton john was
pretty
uh i believe you have to use another
term and i thought that she was hot as
good sandy more than bad sandy
yeah
really yeah i kind of look bad sandy
well there's a surprise
so uh we know look this is one thing too
where he talks about uh talks about
extremism
the left wants to create an echo and i
want to get through this pretty but you
look at twitter you look at how they
responded on twitter uh
with elon musk you look at what they're
doing on social media big tech um we
know that the left is
opposed to hearing any views with they
just with those they disagree with so
here's a poll that we have for you
nearly one quarter 24 of democrats said
they blocked unfriended or stopped
following someone on social media after
the election because of their political
posts on social media fewer than one in
ten this means nine percent of
republicans reported doing the same look
former vice president biden he wants the
supreme court to be an echo chamber he
wants the state legislature to be an
echo chamber he wants twitter to be an
echo chamber they want spotify to be an
echo chamber when jen sackey is saying
we want them to do more to get rid of
misinformation who determines
misinformation the democrats in power
what's crazy to me is when you see those
on the left demanding policies and
actions that will continue that can only
result in an echo chamber and then [ __ ]
about an echo chamber to you and say
they need more oversight over big tech
companies this is the problem that we
run into they're extremists not really
you're in such an echo chamber that only
two members of your party thought that
once a baby is viable outside of the
womb you still shouldn't stick forceps
in its head
you've been in an echo chamber and
you're trying to put everyone else in
these same silos and then bitching about
it
i don't want to call me an extremist
okay fine i guess i'm an extremist go
ahead
slap that label on me put me on your
watch list it's true it's true i believe
that states have the right to if i had
my way i think that uh abortion should
largely be outlawed certainly the way
that it's practiced across the country
but you know what i'll take it going to
the states guess i'm an extremist
hit me for treason how about the rest of
you hands up hands up comment who's an
extremist that you shouldn't kill a baby
yeah like a an out of the womb nine
month
well even in the seven months
i would say uh i would say yeah you
probably shouldn't do that okay well
there you go extremist
all of us
it's like a 90s
skateboarding advertisement i just think
it's extreme
if you're able to choose by then you're
not picking a restaurant have you seen
how wide my pant legs are extreme
at sears yes let's go chase tornadoes
extreme
finger of god this super soaker has two
streams it's extreme
the bigger those got the worst they were
yeah i know the the original super
soaker oh he could kill someone with
that it lasted forever because it was so
concentrated yeah it was like being in a
submarine with a leak just
oh it was great and now they just kept
adding stuff to it you're like this is
stupid it breaks and it leaks i don't
want a backpack no i don't need to carry
all this stuff yeah all i knew was it
was good for me to know who had the
backpack super soaker because i could
hit them first because i knew their dad
was rich yeah of course that's true it
was like 200 yeah and then steal their
uh what was that little
car that my parents would never buy
power wheels oh yeah yeah
i would just look at my friends drive
those and never have one yeah well you
can also just steal them or at least the
hubcaps yeah well that's why my son got
a corvette and
a cadillac well there's a mattel ad you
won't see
in detroit a power wheels carjacking oh
yeah the kids it will happen what am i
i'm just on cinder blocks what happened
hey this kind of smell in here still it
from the other day i was going to say it
it does it does stink it does say
an odor you know what i think that it's
going to be time to uh
people know that we've had someone
pooping in the office a copycat pooper
from amber heard and i think it's time
to put on my detective hat and oh
my word
all right
[Music]
now dave you've been following us as
well i have been
okay
we've had someone who's been emulating
amber heard as a poppy cat copycat poopy
cat pooper poopy cat here in the office
it began with a mug then it was on our
chair and now as you see clearly under
my hat
which by the way we won't get that
deposit back this is a rental
and i had my suspicions
in the office and many of you at mug
club have had your suspicions and
submitted them uh
but i believe that we've been wrong all
along oh
in assuming that the pooper was amongst
us and dare i say assuming that the
pooper
was a copycat that's foreshadowing i'm
like steinbeck here's the thing
i of course first suspected brendan
because
he has
very little self-control
and seems to find these things funny due
to a sophomoric sense of humor but
had to rule that out the moment that i
saw
the fecal transplant that we had on
monday was littered with payday bars and
as you well know dave
allergic to peanut allergic to peanuts
there aren't enough epipens in the world
so my suspicions then moved
to maximus
where he had both
the opportunity
and the motivation
however realizing that he's a four foot
seven mexican the volume of the fecal
matter was far too much to have been
expelled from his orifice that's very
true and that led me to a very likely
suspect
you yourself dave
well
everybody knows that i've been covering
for you for years as you take your
bathroom break as we go to youtube and
it's always more than a large prostate
but often a mud pie well that's true and
believe me it's not solid the way that
it's been with around that's what got
you off the hook i know there is far too
much of a shape
it's bordering on polygonal yes there's
no
rice hold
and then naturally of course uh suspect
because yesterday we had douglas murray
who was sitting in that very chair i
suspected him
but then i realized that was only my
internalized homophobia due to token
owen's constant jokes about loose
sphincter i really thought he was the
perpetrator i know
no some had i think something fell out
of his pant leg when he got out of his
car but there's one thing that we missed
all along dave
yes
and it stood out at me
go on like your faulty shaven mustache i
noticed
a hair
in this poop itself
no way knowing of course that this hair
thick and luscious could not be dave's
not capable of growing such a mustache
doesn't have the testosterone capable i
apologize i did i did
there's only one in this office and that
was thomas finnegan and i searched and
found a dna match it is thomas
finnegan's dna mr finnegan
do you have something to tell me
it wasn't me
take a look right here
take a look
take a look
i did it
you've been crapping in this office the
whole time
no
no it wasn't me you think it's a funny
joke and it's not
you have no proof
do we have any proof tim
actually uh yeah i think we do this
chemo wig fell off
oh
my goodness
it was amber heard all along
you've been dating amber hurt
she's as innocent as the fallen snow
damn it thomas finnegan she has you
under her tread stop standing up for her
no no i love her
i love her
[Music]
that was far too short of a stinger
please stop bringing amber around the
office
i don't know if she was here we didn't
even know it apologies fitting and i was
just feeling the slap
they may have worked together maybe he
was just bringing it in a ziploc uh i
will need a towel
i didn't realize i spilled my whole mug
there's a whole mug spilled on the desk
yes a whole mug spilled on the desk are
we going to amber heard now i think we
should go to amber okay we're going to
go to amber herd again the reason that
we are discussing this is because it's a
study in sociopathic behavior
and misinjury we do right now have a
problem this is a rebound to believe all
women we should believe some women
but everyone deserves their day in court
and right now it's not going very well
for amber heard so let's see
what she oh look she decided to dress
like the caretaker right now you're
going to listen to an accusation yes and
then have due process yes exactly that's
with anybody right unless it's painfully
obvious like we all saw it yes exactly
you know
like looking at amber hurt's face you're
like well when she really what's sad
about it is it's like you're an actress
i know like how do you how many takes do
you do i know who's your coach bridget
nielsen right it's really not good okay
let's see what she's saying right now
uh in new york
it's a fashion event but it's it's just
a major red carpet
and you have to be invited and it's kind
of um
a thing you know and we were invited
that year
and i
uh i had already gone for the previous
year or two
uh oh no we are going to play a drinking
game together drinking stones oh my god
anytime there's an objection any time
she cries can i see it yeah sorry about
that and johnny said it's asking me
bring it up again
this woman um anytime she cries anytime
there's an appeal to sexism any time a
movie is mentioned or any time johnny
depp laughs
is she promoting a new finish the drink
if she left johnny depp laughs about to
finish the drink and of course since
dave is back uh since he's been on the
wagon for a long time you'll just have
to take a diuretic that's fine
i can drink this uh tea right here we'll
call it tea yes
yes opium tea yes i too once fell under
the spell of opium that
it's not a drug if it's opium that's
what i have always comes from a leaf yes
flower the natural plant parasites
let's see what she says in my experience
with him it wasn't just one
so you'd make a point and then he would
go on to a different accusation
but i remember that what started it is
this accusation that i
had been flirting at this event
we get back to the hotel room
and johnny shoves me
and kind of grabs me by the collarbone
area like not really my neck but
top of my neck
top of my above my collarbone below my
neck
top of your amish scarf yes i i think at
that point when we were still right now
she's living with harrison ford and
witness but i can't i i don't really
recall um
too many specifics i remember he threw a
bottle at me
it means i broke the chandelier that's
pretty specific and at some point that's
an angle of attack uh i don't remember
specifics but in ricochet you only
remember bits and pieces of the most
violent fight between the married
couples johnny and i are in a struggle
in the living room and
he kind of like shoves me down on the
sofa and i get up and i'm trying to get
him off of me and it's just
stronger than me i don't know how else
to describe it ridiculous and at some
point he just whacks me in the face
and
i had not
at the time
been
like i didn't i think that was the first
time i was like is this a broken nose
at the time i was unsure what that
feeling was um
but i suspect well now
and
other than that i was relatively quick
my nose
uh but i remember other than that that's
such a okay talk about
trying to play coy i mean i don't know
what
he threw a bottle and it bounced off and
it broke the chandelier and he broke my
nose but
other than that i was unscathed trying
to present herself as beautiful and
brave while also presenting herself as
the victim i'm sorry
but drink and just so you can see that
is in fact
cinco de mayo cerveza which is by the
way you need to go to dave chandeliers
where we hang them yes correctly a beer
bottle's not gonna take down their
mineral spirit bottle proof yes what are
mineral spirits i've heard that
mentioned so many times in this do you
know do you know what middle mineral
spirits i think you know i don't okay
i didn't know i figured you know neither
one of us are that cultured but you did
consume substances i thought uh i i
can't maybe i i've i've had it but i
honestly have no idea what's up in my
head what it is like angostura bitters
can someone bring it up inside i know
you can light a fire with it
serpentine interpreting substitute and
petroleum spirits
i'm sorry so it's gasoline and they were
drinking it
that's a nice mix right yes i will have
the gas i will have the uh 87 octane
old-fashioned yes what kind of hotel
rooms do you have i'm going to need
huffing rags and a chandelier yes and
don't forget for throwing don't forget
our two diesel martini lunch yes
let's see what she's saying here are you
filming those in new york okay and where
was mr depp at that time
johnny was in l.a at the time
bracelets saying i'll have all of them
at some point eventually
no need for the receipt i'm walking out
with them
all right and what if i will not be
returning
did you have with mr depp relating to
james franco in that time frame of may
2014
oh my god that's a lie by face drink
yeah because she has to think about her
answer nightmare um
well if it's a nightmare say it
i
wanted to do this independent film i
god movie mentioned i liked the story i
liked the character
i
was a character a raging [ __ ]
it was
they saw a lot of me in that character
guys you guys are in charge of it we
have no idea what's going on
okay another side he's not even playing
the drinking game he just wants to be
drunk yeah
i get how much you want what's the over
under on johnny depp having a flask in
that suit jacket oh okay
hey by the way i think there's a we can
probably grab another channel that just
has a stream going on this is a network
there are channels on youtube that have
it going non-stop so we don't have to
wait for a commercial break but just
that it's
was a nightmare here let me just show
you one thing if uh so control room pull
up the james franco clip of them in the
elevator keep in mind and this is where
the lie gets built upon the lie and the
lie and the lie and amber heard had to
fire her or she chose to fire her pr for
not a good idea in the middle of the
case here's a big reason why
when uh of course it was alleged that
she had cheated on johnny depp with
jimmy franco her attorney said they just
happened to be in the same elevator
together
well if you watch the tape you can
clearly see not only do they try and
avoid the camera but they sort of cuddle
by putting their heads together and they
only go to the penthouse which can only
be reached by the person who lives in
the penthouse or the person has to be
with them james franco was not getting
off at any other floor so they present
an argument
and then okay you see the footage then
they present another argument well they
were just friends and johnny depp was
paranoid and so that becomes more
clinical level of gas lighting as well
we would just happen to be the same
elevator yeah but you went to the same
place and you well you're just being
we're just friends but you didn't say
that you were friends you said that you
happen to be in the same elevator and
the story keeps changing if you haven't
been following it since the beginning so
whenever they get that uh you guys can
bring it up but let's hear her talking
more look she's making me she's making
the face
things and i get up i can't believe the
hollywood
romance workout
resolve to just sit the rest of the time
up
at the front of the plane
oh no
and she's a regular rosa parks
i got that uh the video
sit in the back of the private learjet
now
you're there cuddling in the elevator oh
yeah here we go let's bring this up
you can bring the music down a little
bit but this is keep in mind right they
just happen to be in the same elevator
was a legal argument only one floor is
hit the penthouse she's in a robe i
believe this is three in the morning
yeah her and james franco don't know
each other yeah that's a normal way to
that's how you yeah it's good acting on
both your parts by the way exactly
he's just like
geez amber heard i didn't know that you
were banging elon musk
so i if you keep having sex with elon
musk i'll never get you a part in my
movie if we go far back into the left
it's like we're not together yeah by the
way when you zoom out there's just jay
barachel masturbating yeah
[Laughter]
no i didn't want to be a sad sack or a
worry word all right let's see what
she's lying about now
and i just
look at him one more time
wanting to penetrate the monster to see
the man oh my god underneath that you
wanted to be penetrated by his monster
and he tells me to hurry up penetrating
the monster
and i who talks like this
my back is turned to him and i feel this
let the record show that uh her back was
in fact turned to the monster
to penetrate it kicked me
in the back kicked me in the back
i think she's gonna cry fell on the
floor i caught myself on the floor and i
just felt like i was looking at the
floor floor of the plane
you don't feel like you're looking you
were looking at the floor of the plane
i thought to myself i think i think we
should drink when johnny's glasses come
off all right
drink when johnny's glasses come off
is that the rules
no but that's a good one
yeah like you could
you could hear a pin drop on that plane
you could feel the tension but no one
did anything
just didn't happen probably yeah i just
remember feeling so
embarrassed
on the plane was like could you stop
kicking your wife
all right hold on a second that's a
great drink that's a cry also she's
using by the way
she's using language that she believes
she's no one who is kicked in the back
on a plane in front of people abused
their first instinct is
embarrassed what she's trying to emulate
is when people say hey a lot of rape
victims feel shame afterwards
particularly if it's some kind of
relationship where maybe things went too
far and they feel as though they were
guilted and and they were blaming their
outfit or were they that is true and
it's wrong for people to feel shame
about that but for her to say i had the
[ __ ] kicked out of me on an airplane in
front of people and i just felt ashamed
and embarrassed that's not a genuine
emotion she's trying to copy emotions
she thinks she should feel yeah and
especially during the act of it that's
not how you feel no you get mad you get
scared
and you get you're gonna get helped yes
there's no i don't know who you were on
the plane with but anybody's gonna be
like dude what are you doing yeah
there's i can't imagine
even the pilot's probably looking back
like i think we should land this yeah i
think this is i don't know if this is
certified as an air emergency but we
don't have any marshals on here yeah the
the guy who looks like he's in a band is
kicking his wife
and he continued to drink and then
eventually
started howling like an animal
and passed out in the bathroom
with the door locked okay he's just kind
of laughing right there yeah yeah he's
just laughing
the way she told the story is this he
landed filled with playing field yeah he
did left yeah
oh god
we need another beer for stephen i think
he mouth started howling
[Laughter]
there's a little too much frost but
aside from that
it's empty okay
well the piles of too much somebody
howling back there yeah it's just a guy
who's just kicked his wife to the ground
he's now holly jack sparrow yeah she
wants us to believe that it was this it
was a
she felt embarrassed oh
yeah this all sounds like it happened
yeah this sounds like the flight with
ric flair yes she's confusing it
is that a wolf it's my thing
makes
makes the flight with ric flair the
concorde yes yes
looks like pan am back when you could
party on the plane all right let's keep
listening to her
[Music]
how can that call for speculation i'll
sustain rejection
let's go to defendants 221.
guys we need someone to sign that we
have like three more drinks here and
nothing to drink
dave what do you want to drink do you
want to oh i have something down here
okay extra i can pour in
now i just drank the foam
my day's
ruined but i mean at this point i might
as well be pee every time this happens
yes exactly listen
by the way he also peed on her in the
middle of the plane and no one did
anything but you like it she likes it
and she's like why won't anyone do
anything we're not gonna do anything
we're not human beings yes there's
trump peeing on russian prostitutes yeah
exactly the side of the plane the left
it's like people who are just living
their life with no accountability like
the left or like someone like amber
heard uh
they just always overreach with the lie
well you have johnny depp who
like he trashed a hotel in the 80s when
he was young which was a party it wasn't
him solo right and then every woman
who's ever dated him is like yeah he's
not abusive no well it's like you know
what justin bieber justin bieber when
i've seen him recently he was 14 he was
15 he did stupid things he seems like a
decent guy now yeah i don't i really i
don't have any hate for justin bieber i
used to think he was a dick i'm like
what would happen if you were 15 and you
had 500 million dollars well that was a
who was it uh the guy from lonely allen
and snl who said it perfectly he's like
he's 19 years old and has 100 million
dollars i can only imagine the trouble i
would get in if i was 19 and had 100
dollars right yeah you got to give him a
little bit of slack for being young you
can't just be mad at somebody because
they're doing the same dumb stuff you
are but have way more access to things
though you're still wearing the same
dumb things johnny depp well he's well
you know why i think he's a decent man
because he's very close friends with
alice cooper who was a supremely decent
man well he knows a lot of comics and i
i know uh dude a lot of people know him
and i've never heard bad things about
johnny depp until now the only thing i
will say is uh we were extras on the
film the secret window or my dad was he
was very nice but he faked like he could
speak french and he can't
yeah it doesn't make him bad but i do
see that it makes him want to be
pretentious a little bit well yeah
there's always a pretentious all right
speaking of pretentious let's go back to
the none have you ever met an actor that
wasn't pretentious though like a good
actor
clint eastwood
have you met clint
eric roberts eric roberts is awesome
he's a great actor he's done crap but he
was not pretentious i love eric
robertson no i've met yeah eric's cool
as hell okay yeah patrick warburton too
patrick uh i didn't meet him yeah i did
meet patrick warburton i met him too
yeah
no but your point stands yeah for the
most for the most part yeah well eric
roberts is just cool he just says yes to
everything right he did my friend's
movie on christmas because it was the
only day he wasn't working and he goes
what do you want uh me to pay you and he
goes i like an omelette and that's all i
wanted
it's always just that is for what you
say because i can't cook my own omelette
yeah because they took my thumbs
challenge they took my dad
my times
we should do that as an intro i can't
believe we haven't done a problem
i did write a poke greenwich village one
that i need to send in because i i just
i'm like i think we talked about
i think you and i are the only two
people who know that film really i well
ken does for sure okay but i i i'd like
to know well bryce probably does but
there's
there's not a lot of people that know
that movie it's not great but there are
some great performances i love that
movie i like it yeah yeah but it's also
it's there are some it's there are some
plot holes for sure
it's definitely got uh way too long of
shots there's there's a lot of 80s
issues with it yeah but i do love that
film you know he's gonna have issues
when they're 80 this sociopath right
here ever heard let's see what she has
to say
[Music]
hey we need some more beer
oh this is the tape of johnny depp
howling like an animal what it really
means is he was moaning in pain
and hey by the way this is a guy who had
an opiate addiction because he lost his
finger my point here that we're that i'm
making you guys can listen this isn't
new the the himalayas
had an opinion yeah well i knew that but
what about his finger well yeah she
threw a bottle of vodka at him a handful
of vodka that's what severed his finger
he had to have surgery and then uh he
got uh mercy got staff that's right i
didn't realize how severe it was when i
got out of my foot two years ago um
like you can get you can get sepsis it's
really really bad easily oh yeah
absolutely you can yeah and uh so he was
in pain now remember we always tell oh
mental health oh addiction health right
we tell people to get help and they
should yes
if you have an opiate addiction but
do you think that people are going to be
open with their opiate addiction if
right now he's being condemned for sure
it sounds like he was drunk he by the
way he doesn't sound violent he sounds
like uh
in pain it does sound pathetic and i'm
sure that's embarrassing for johnny depp
but do you think that people men or
women are more likely or less likely to
get help if you decide to embarrass them
on a public stage in order to try and
extort them for money well of course and
i mean the problem is is it's still
extremely stigmatized yeah and anytime
you can bring in any sort of illegal
activity even if it's legally prescribed
he he may have obtained it in a
different way and that's the problem is
anytime that you can talk about
addiction no matter what it was with him
right it could be overspending whatever
you can find on somebody
that they can admit to
you know what here let's see anything it
can be
because that's a really good point and i
think a lot and i honestly dave i really
do appreciate when you're open about
this because i you know we've talked in
privately i don't want to bring up the
addiction stuff fine and i think that
you help a lot of people when you
discuss this
um i think we both discussed having
mental health issues in the past we both
have because
i don't want it to only come up when
it's political football when people say
usually mental health only comes up when
it's a school shooting and one side
wants to say oh it's not guns it's
mental health the right does that
and then the left says we don't want to
stigmatize mental health if some
celebrity commits suicide but then the
left uses it against people the society
in general uses it against people and i
think there's a difference between
judgment which is a good thing and
stigmatizing and shame in other words we
all need to make judgments you cross the
street you're making a judgment
sooner or later you're making a judgment
yourself that you have a problem
right you haven't you have a problem
with whatever it is pills
hair i don't i don't know what it is
whatever drug it is could be alcohol
sooner or later you're making a judgment
but someone should be able to make a
judgment bring their judgment to someone
else and get help when they bring it to
someone who can help them
and then that's used against them that's
when you end up stigmatizing people and
that's what's happening right now
well and also if you have like a court
ordered you know obviously that is a
judgment but when you actually follow it
and you go okay this is something that i
i realize i've made a mistake i want to
change my life they can use that court
order against you and you're treated
like a criminal instead of an addict
right so because sometimes you have to
hit rock bottom and rock bottom comes in
a lot of different ugly ways yeah
but you're right i mean i i have several
mental health issues prior to the
caribbean
yes well yeah
you don't turn
well for that money rock bottom that's
down with davey's locker oh please i'll
do 30 of those yeah i'll play a waiter i
love how johnny depp's like i hate this
character i'm tired of it and they're
like oh okay well we're not gonna have
you in the sixth one he's like what
that's my life come on what
i don't want to go back to benny and
june let's not be rash come on
i don't even answer tim burton's phone
calls anymore we've made a mess together
i mean how many diagonal shots do you
need this is please
are they taking a break they're on a
break livestream will what does shortly
mean do we know what shortly means
they're uh token are they taking they're
not taking their lunch break are they 11
30. it looks like they might be taking a
short recess taking a short recess so
you know what let's do this if i don't
know if we want to go to uh do you want
to take some chats right now on youtube
this is usually something we do with mug
club but let's take chats for about five
to ten minutes
on the johnny depp situation amber hurt
if that's what we want to do you let me
know again i'm kind of going through
this blind
uh
and then if they come back we can
continue covering it if you're watching
right now you can usually join
lightweight.com club we take a few chats
every day thursday we take a lot of
chats
and of course we usually have another
segment
or another game something like that but
let's uh let's take another segment too
if we wanted to go into that no i don't
think we need to go to the summit i'd
like to take some chats on what people
think about the amber heard johnny depp
situation because i have been very
surprised to see the i thought it would
be maybe a 50 50 split it's not no well
i'm very surprised
even at first i was a little bit
surprised by
how many people didn't really believe
her right but i i was not surprised by
the number of people that immediately
demonized johnny depp took away his
career or at least wanted to yeah took
away you know it he just you have a
track record of being in the public
spotlight
since the early 80s and this is the
first time it's come up
i think you should you know at least
give
you know a little bit of uh time before
you just jump on somebody yeah that's
right that's our society yeah the second
you can hurt somebody and the second you
can take their career away there's a lot
of people out there that just want to do
that it's it's the inability to achieve
something and just to immediately try to
kill off somebody else yeah now it was
right away jumping on it and honestly uh
not like i remember we told some jokes
about it but nothing really serious
because we didn't know then when the
tapes came out of amber heard you know
hitting him and talking about hitting
him yeah i remember feeling re like this
is just
awful him being railroaded because again
working in the media you see the
groundswell and how much of a trend it
was that johnny depp was abusive wasn't
really in our wheelhouse so we didn't
spend a lot of time in it but i was
aware of just it was sort of this gold
mine it was like a witch hunt of how
many people could just you know get some
kind of a scoop on johnny depp and i
remember thinking you're gonna have a
lot of people who heard that and they're
not going to know that she was wailing
on him
well yeah i mean correct me if i'm wrong
but i believe johnny depp's own daughter
came out and said you know he wasn't she
was right and
that was ignored because it's like well
come on it's his daughter she's
defending him but i i think that's
important yeah well her own psychologist
the one who she hired by the way
yesterday who
showed incredible gender bias by saying
you know often the woman being abused
just assumed that it was a woman and it
turns out she has never actually given
an evaluation or testimony uh
at least in the last five or ten years
that involved a man being abused outside
of a same-sex couple right
and
we know beyond any shadow of a doubt
that
women commit domestic abuse against men
more than men committed against women
and that's what's reported and we all
know that it's under-reported now this
is why her own psychologist was arguing
or a clinical psychologist i believe was
arguing the severity of the injuries are
worse because men are more powerful no
one's arguing that of course i mean i've
been hit by a woman everyone here has
been hit by some woman at some point we
talked about that a long time mother
yeah well you know when we had it coming
that's there's
there's an immunity for mother
grandmother
yeah well
i don't know how that happened she came
back from the grave just to wamp on you
that is
that is powerfully bad behavior
what um
what we don't discuss is okay the
severity of injuries are more severe
from abuse of women got it yes
it doesn't change the fact that women
try more and what about in this instance
it's irrelevant because she injured him
by throwing a glass bottle at him
in other words the injury argument is no
longer relevant here because she if you
use a weapon that's why a gun is a great
equalizer sure a man is stronger than a
woman which by the way is considered
offensive and sexist outside of a legal
case we're trying to say well sure she
hit him but she can't hurt him she used
to look at a little poor little girl
johnny depp is you know he's this
brooding epitome of masculinity well yes
he's all man
yes
he was out doing black mass which nobody
bought him as the lead right
him in his his turtle dove like brittle
chest
[Laughter]
throwing overhand rights at amber heard
and this is where we are this is the
these are the arguments her own
psychologist said yes she hit him but
the question became is it reactive
violence and i think it was johnny
depp's attorney saying okay so she
throws a but someone who's defending
themselves do they typically throw a
bottle someone's face
she said well it could be reactive okay
he said if they miss
do they typically throw a second one
well it would depend on the context and
then in any context where the allegation
was that johnny depp got physical with
her it was abuse i don't know i don't
really think that a bottle of mineral
spirits is a great
weapon for self-defense
but i don't even really know what
mineral spirits is it's uh apparently
turpentine right and with the amount
that he smokes not a good idea not a i
mean not a good idea to drink turpentine
in general that's what i've always said
yeah i mean it's safe it's a safe stance
yeah i agree but you know what we don't
need to be edgy all the time let's grab
some chats and see what people are
saying here about uh amber heard and
johnny depp okay john johnston wants to
know do you think johnny depp gets more
opportunities in hollywood post trial or
less absolutely more
i absolutely think that he gets more i
don't know how many more but i
absolutely think that he's in a better
position after this trial than he was
before this trial because all whether he
wins the defamation or not and i talked
about this with uh half asian lawyer
bill richmond and last wednesday
you know he needs to prove that she
knowingly lied and that it did damages
to him
that's kind of a tough hurdle to clear
whether he wins that or not he's already
won
well the people that are going to go see
his movies you know
they weren't going to go see him anyway
the people that will always hold on
that's the problem with with now is if
you get accused of something you're
going to be guilty to a certain number
of people in the public right because
they won't let it go and they will just
assume you're always the abuser because
that allows them to always continue
playing that victim card and have that
narrative
but i think he's going to have way more
opportunities because they hated him
anyway but people do like johnny depp
it's why he's been successful for so
long he's good at what he does and
there's no reason why you wouldn't want
to have a bankable star back and he was
kind of aging out a little bit yeah so
this puts him back into the spotlight so
i think he will actually get more
opportunities as well well they said
that uh he had to take a lot of crappy
films because of some of the financial
burdens that he had yes and this was
just because of a liquidity issue so
that's why he did a few what was that
movie the with the artificial
intelligence thing where you download
your brain transcendence transcendence
just oh god it was terrible but he had
to do those and so it was like pirates
of the caribbean and crap but since then
he hasn't really done anything since the
amber heard allegations no he's been
able to yeah he hasn't been able to so i
don't see how it could get any worse and
certainly i think at the worst in the
worst case scenario for johnny depp
going forward now it's
all right this was an unhealthy this was
a toxic relationship from both sides
right that's at best that amber heard
can argue
and i think a lot of people are going to
understand that
to a degree sure i think i think it was
toxic i think he was probably angry i
think he was probably temperamental and
i don't see any evidence that he
physically abused her i don't either and
i think that if anybody's being honest
we've all in our life been in an
argument where you lose control you're
pissed off your emotions get the better
of you and people want to act like
they've never been in a situation now
yeah obviously throwing bottles hitting
you know
ripping off part of somebody's finger
you know there's there's extents that we
all don't cross but we've all been
in that moment where whether it's with
anybody even where you just turn red and
you do something regrettable yeah which
i'm willing to of course look at her
it's a very forgivable thing right but
it seems that this is sort of her
her usual well she agreed to terms
here's the problem is there's a
difference between you know explosive
anger that happens like you said it
happens probably in every relationship
at some point where of course the woman
and the man they get mad they lose
control and that's that's a bad thing
shouldn't happen but it does happen it's
a part of life it's realistic if you're
in a relationship right
there's a difference between that and
then proactively settling which she did
she got seven million dollars amber
heard
and then after that and signing a
non-disclosure to settle so that you
keep it private for his children right
that was a big reason for it she got
more money than she'd ever earned at
that point up
as far as i understood it although her
work and never back down was
i can't believe she hasn't made more yes
it's from what i'm saying yeah great
she's a daniel day lewis yes actually
she's probably hamming it up about like
daniel day lewis this is about as
believable as daniel day lewis doing my
left foot yeah
on the stand
i'm playing human is really great yeah
yeah
she uh agreed settled
and then when aquaman was coming out had
someone ghost right and signed off on
being a victim of abuse capitalizing on
the metoo trend
and then told him well you go ahead and
go out and say this is what's a record
recorded phone call you go out and tell
them that you're a man a victim of
domestic abuse you tell the world johnny
see who they believe that's not uh
reactive anger that is proactive abuse
that is proactive manipulation
regardless of the fights if we can all
agree that the fights are a tit for tat
and i don't know that that's the case
let's assume the fights are a tip that
phone call tells you that it's not
though that's right problem but and i
agree but let's say the fight yeah yeah
no i get it i can type it but i agree no
it's not even tit-for-tat but let's even
say if it was she's mad and he's mad
well
since then it's not
he tried to settle
he didn't go after her
he didn't drag her name through the mud
he wanted to keep it private he gave her
money that she wouldn't be entitled to
anyway
and then she went forward and she
decided to try and be destructive to get
her name over the top two very very
different approaches and it would be
unrealistic to
and i'm not saying it's impossible to
believe that she was the angel she
portrays herself to be in that marriage
he was a monster and then after the
marriage him be the silent
non-confrontational one in her to be on
the attack on the attack on the attack
there's usually a pattern of behavior
and that was recognized by both
psychologists what really just comes
into question is was johnny depp as
abusive as amber heard her own
lawyers aren't saying that she wasn't
they cannot claim she wasn't abusive
they're just saying well maybe she was
abused more well then it's a wash as far
as i'm concerned well and whatever
happened he settled with the fact and
knowing that he was the person who was
going to be looked at like garbage for
the rest of his life
with that non-disclosure and that she
was going to be able to do movies i mean
he was his career was ruined by it to a
degree there's no doubt about it well i
think they they settled before she came
out and did that
well yeah oh yeah i think they said it
was like all right look we just both get
divorced here's the money and we just go
on our merry way and she said okay took
the money said she would give it to
charity and then she wrote the op-ed so
she made the accusation the charity
thing but i thought she had mentioned
okay she might have mentioned him but
then she wrote the op-ed which is what
get him got him fired that i knew after
she took the money okay and it's like
well you can't do don't you took you
took the money so that you wouldn't keep
going forward and try and use this to
advance your career and i think that's
what rubs people the wrong way because
they saw it play out in the public eye
and the timing is just too convenient
for her well you wanted your cake and to
eat it too and then to eat some more yes
and uh
she's looking like she's eating a little
bit more cake maybe it's just some
stress eating well it could be the it's
a frumpy gown yes well she wants
everyone to know that she's just like
you yeah i also have no taste yes she's
just like you dressed like a nun yeah
except when she's getting into an
elevator and sweats getting ready to get
railed by franco yes
[Laughter]
by the way that's more screen time than
he's gotten in a while too yeah you
don't see a lot of them well that's what
happens when you're on the set of palo
alto texting your
your parts to underagers
which i don't think he ever got in
trouble for that well i don't know he's
just he's he's just a pretentious prick
where he got his honorary degree from
colombia and he's like yeah i wrote 19
fiction have you tried reading any of
his books no it's unbelievably bad yeah
it's like his everyone talks as always
is genius who's hyperly focused and he's
hyperly productive
read any of his crap you're like oh yeah
this professor just wanted to be able to
say yeah james franco in a class well
yeah they also go he you know he's like
the next james dean because he you know
play james dean
because it's like yeah because he looks
like him in a red jacket yes also i
nothing against james dean we don't
really know how that story would have
turned out no he only did three films
yeah he lost his head pretty quickly
literally
uh during his hollywood career
did three films james and one was one
was very very good can you name the
films one was east of eden right east of
eden east of eden uh
obviously rebel without a cause
and then what was the third i should
know it was a western
uh wasn't it a western
giant
giant it was western though yeah uh i
don't it wasn't like a western the cloud
it was but it was set in the in the west
in the west like on a ranch i believe
yeah yeah well was it is that what it
was okay i remember it was like
i've honestly never seen i've only seen
east of eden and uh obviously rebel
thought yeah yeah without a question i
never saw a giant either yeah east of
eden was okay
yeah it was all right he was good in it
though he was good in it but a lot of
people
it's because he died james dean so they
want to say that he was the best i
actually think he was better than marlon
brando but uh i don't know how it would
have ended up probably would have ended
up fat and on the crapper well a lot
like marlon brando yes who just hated
i love marlon brando though i just like
that he hated everything he did yeah
it's like dude why
you just get you get to be an actor
that's great at your job and you're
angry at life and i love how they used
to stage the scenes around him
afterwards so he could just remain
seated like people thought it's like oh
it was first character no he's just like
yo come here
uh you okay man
what do you what you would he say
they're like okay can you just walk two
steps it's not in my contract
there's supposed to be like a huge fight
scene at the end of apocalypse now yeah
and he showed up like drunk and didn't
know his lines so they just let him do
his thing yeah it ended up being pretty
good that's like steven seagal steven
seagal got so fat he couldn't do the
fight scenes you're like okay he's gonna
throw a front kick and you're gonna you
know you're gonna sidestep you're gonna
block and he's like i wouldn't do that
like
i would just do this
[Laughter]
like everyone else like doing these
acrobats and he's just like
well yeah on apocalypse now he there's a
scene where he's just like into the
character and i don't know if it was
because he was great at method or he's
just lazy but he's doing the lines as
colonel kurtz and a bug just crawls in
his mouth and he eats and he just goes i
ate a bug and then he just keeps talking
[Laughter]
he also had uh there was a uh burger
king right by his house he would pay a
kid to take all the remaining food at
the end of the night and he would throw
it over the fence of marlon brando's
house and then he would just like is
that true it's true grab all the bur i
can say this honestly grab all the
burger king and go back well that's just
self-punishment at that point he has the
money oh he was but yeah did you see him
in island of dr maria no i did but i
didn't okay look he was yes i supposed
to wear any of that
i saw him
i didn't make the leap that he had the
burger king boy throw bags of trash into
his yard i assumed that he ate a lot of
her money expensive high quality food
because it was rich no
god no this was this was a sexy leading
man who then played uh vito corleone and
then after was like i'll just ruin my
body oh the burger king in my yard i
just can't imagine it
how disgusting is that i have uh i was i
was looking up dave's burger king thing
and i have something is this true yeah
it is true
can we just stop
i don't think i've ever heard anything
more disgusting
well i i might i might have something to
top it uh john
world's clyde we're back to the trial
but really fast johnny depp said that he
loved his fart so much he compared uh
them to god marlon brando
uh depp said my own tear-filled laughter
gave up the charade i reached into my
pocket and revealed the culprit marlin's
face lit up like a christmas tree the
smile of a five-year-old i handed the
fart unit to him he held it up to the
light and exclaimed i found god i was so
proud that after a couple of years of
being on the receiving end of marlin's
practical jokes i was finally able to
swing back and connect big time wait is
a fart machine but we were both winners
as the fart machine became a source of
entertainment for many years
oh wow they have a sense of humor like a
six-year-old boy and they're both
wondering burger king kids club crowns
that's true
mr uh mr brando i admire your catalogue
of work i celebrate all of it uh and
i believe that we share common ground
over mineral spirits in this flatulence
machine
yeah
also circumstances
you can keep uh you can keep all the
rings and like get the head of the food
yes i appreciate it i uh i have always
had a fondness for your
uh burger king trash thrown over your
fence uh you take risks i eat it on all
fours
it's brave brave choice
this is why you make the choices
so even though i like johnny depp they
are pretentious pricks they do i know i
love both of them
i can only imagine the director just
like oh son of a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
what sorry what were you saying joking
out i said the trial trial's coming back
but right now is what she's taking her
oath
she's taking her oath that she's going
to immediately break
oh there's no audio yet
all right by the way
if anybody wants to throw mcdonald's
trash over my
when i'm older i i'll totally tape a 20
to the front so many similarities i
would wager between me and dave though
he the differences that bring us apart
he prefers mcdonald's i
have a pension for whataburger thrown
over my
it's not so much a fence as it is uh
really more of a of a
a steel barrier but uh it's a style
great
choices
i originally wanted uh wendy's but uh
the frosties would just go everywhere
and cause ants yes he had a problem with
frosties he used to yell at them and
accuse him of being nothing more than a
thick glorified milkshake
and he pooped in the bed
[Laughter]
but he did so with no malice you imagine
if marlon brando pooped in your bed oh
my gosh like sunk in yeah you're like
was there a rhino in here be like the
reverse princess and the pea
[Laughter]
all right let's see what's happening
with amber hurt him
thank you
thank you thank you
try the fish yes i'll be here all week
did you reach out to try the friendship
right objection you are hearsay and
bleeding
your honor i would direct your owner's
attention to
the
uh tablet lighting up in front of her
it's like someone telling a scary story
by the campfire
sense impression and
uh
and they found hanging from the door
state of mind a gold digging [ __ ] no
i want you to dress like the judge yes
you never get off yes
without the shoulder pads
everything about this just seems
calculated they keep cutting the audio
with this thing all right well that's
why we're here with you okay you can
yeah we're trying for you we're giving
you the old colleagues but it really is
something yeah it really is something to
try and keep this alive you guys can
smash the like button if you want more
of this uh let's uh take a chat and uh
see what uh see what people are saying
about the show what is what
this is steel tumbler
i don't know why i find that so funny
it's like like these actors we think
that they're distinguished and they have
these yachts but he's wearing you know
the already pre-assembled suit from
jcpenney drinking from a generic steel
tumbler that he got at like some kind of
a furniture convention that was my my
favorite was uh when hulk hogan was on
was uh i forgot what the trial was it
was gawker about it was gucker the sex
tape wasn't it or no it might have been
the sex tape yeah it may have been that
um but he came in just in his usual like
sort of wrestling yellow garb you know
yeah and the judge is like you have to
tone it down so the next day comes in a
black bandana and a giant chain
just he just like he just went to nwo
era right
yeah he just came in this bad hulk hogan
and the judge is like uh you know fine
whatever this is at least you tried it
didn't help him where every time they
asked a question he went yeah
what
[Laughter]
that is the funniest sex tape it's not
even a sex tape it's just a guy talking
about how he's full naked in a bed
i mean he made mr nanny that makes that
makes that movie look i also made uh was
it thunder uh
thunder in paradise thunder and paradise
and then suburban commando that's right
for lloyd i remember suburban commander
i thought they're back oh are they back
all right let's hear let's uh hear what
she has to lie the communication between
you and rocky pennington your best
friend is that correct
that's correct objection hearsay
and they cut the audio again
how was it hearsay if she was just asked
if something was correct that's what i i
don't know that seems odd
i'm not a lawyer but i do play one on
television and that seems strange
amber is like really i would like to sit
down with you for a nice character study
it's like you're if you're playing a
lawyer it's going to be the same thing
you always play yes
but you do
she shows up in aquaman with glasses and
a law book
i didn't even know she was in aquaman
because i've never seen it yeah
my son had no interest i had no interest
i mean
you really have to stretch to make the
world in danger from sharks yeah i think
we we talked about it but it was like an
idea for entourage because they're like
well here's a hero where they'll never
make a movie about it so we can just
have it in this
and then they did yeah i know and then
they made gatsby as well which they
somehow made worse than the movie
entourage did oh well you didn't you
didn't like gatsby you didn't like it
with the jay z sound drive oh yeah
didn't make sense that people were
dancing on a bridge in model ts to rap
music while no one was driving the cars
you know i was wondering a little it
seems
the only film worse than great gatsby
that i can think of what because the
ending was awful and i love i love leo
in movies but it's like yeah it was i
couldn't wait for him to get shot yeah i
went what was it was it uh was it
is it puffy now is it p diddy is it sean
comes what does he go by uh what does it
go by come on
i know i get it that i am the [ __ ]
for not knowing but didn't he show up in
the film wasn't he in the club scene or
am i thinking of someone else was it j
it was jay-z or was puffy was one of
those really really rich i only remember
toby mcguire for a second and i honestly
don't remember any other part of that
joel edgarton was it one of was it
i know outcast was a soundtrack but i
don't i did a lot of the soundtrack but
i don't think it was one of them i don't
know the only thing the ending was awful
spoiler alert if you didn't see the
great gatsby uh the only ending worst uh
worse than that was king kong with the
one the peter jackson that's terrible
the last line from jack black there you
go he goes
i guess in the end
zoom out
it was the beauty that killed the beast
that's how you're going to end it and
jack black saying it's they're back to
the trail but uh puffy goes by love now
what
no
no
no i'm not gonna do it he legally
changed his name to sean love combs
guess what i don't give a [ __ ] he was
puff daddy then he was p diddy then he
was diddy then he was puffy i might be
getting in the crowd he was sean combs
around monstrous ball because he wanted
to be an actor that's right yeah that's
right
now he wants to be love
love is that's feminine no i'm not gonna
no i'm not gonna wait no thanks puffy
puff daddy p diddy diddy
love
how about how about silly prick
they've gotten progressively worse
oh i want to put them in a prison cell
with the edge from you too like yeah you
two fight it out over who gets the
shittiest nickname
that you gave yourself yeah we fight to
the death and we kill the winner yeah
exactly like spartacus
all right let's see she's making uh
she's making her resting angel face
did you what if any communication did
you have
with your mother or your father
following this incident objection here
say
sustain that um
let's go to let's go to defendants 222
and
just spend the seven million on a lawyer
we're going to be back up all right
thank you
we know she didn't give it to the aclu
no
and they muted why did they keep muting
it's like well this one's not because of
an objection we just find her to be
shrill
oh johnny depp's other lawyer needs to
wash her hair i know
not a good look right now he's just
talking to us like have you ever
considered dry shampoo yes
you're sitting next to a movie star
maybe you should sit on the other side
of the table not next to me yes and i
and if i'm saying that that must be
quite severe because it's well known
that i don't bathe but uh at least
present myself as i do yes i i've i've
smoked 38 cigarettes outside and you
smell way worse than i don't know how
that happens didn't you go to cornell
yes
is that my jacket
oh and that other guy is sitting there
with it's like don't sit with your palm
that way you look gay i know he's just
leaning
what are we gonna say next so johnny
what happ in donnie brasco i was a
little confused about oh we're back oh i
think i said objection
[Laughter]
is a great film yeah that's honestly my
favorite johnny depp film i love dying
brosco
i like it more than godfather i know
it's a different kind of film but i
donnie brasco is one of my favorite
movies in that genre and i feel like
it's overlooked oh i agree and i'll give
you i'll give you two reasons
michael and madsen mm-hmm
that is an underutilized fantastic actor
in my book i love him in movies
he hasn't chatter you want to go back
let's go back yeah let's go back they
throw them in stuff like i've seen in b
movies every now and then on like a
plane
but every part he's in is great yeah i
know i watch movies on planets like eric
roberts i can't believe they're allowed
on planes i'm like this is some hardcore
nudity and just available to watch out
yeah the watchman was on a plane yeah
it's just
oh the blue genitals
are they're muting again i don't mean
this makes it impossible it's almost a
stop start as a former vice president
biden's state of the union address yeah
this is how his brain works yes
and look even right now look at her face
look at her face it's just like
i'm sorry
i didn't mean to duty in your bed i
didn't it was just a prank here's the
difference as if he goes uh well they
say did you do drugs yes i did they say
did you drink yes did you break cabinets
yes i did break uh i've been in a fight
with a cabinet or two in my day you know
he's sitting there and he's kind of
being sorry okay maybe you can say he's
being a little bit arrogant but he
admitted to it where she goes the
pooping was a prank
well the bottle it was an accident okay
i'm sorry i didn't punch you the right
way
when you see a pattern if someone never
accepting responsibility that's what
makes it tough it's really tough to be
in a relationship uh or friendship if
you have a mother a father a son who can
never be wrong we've all had that person
i don't mean someone who's hard-headed i
mean someone who can never be wrong and
never be responsible for their own
mistakes and that's why that's
ultimately what i think if you had to
pin it down to one thing
is that johnny depp
put himself at risk
was willing to expose all of his flaws
for the world to see and accept
responsibility for them and he's just
said i just didn't do this part which is
what she's saying the abuse that didn't
happen did i do drugs yesterday was i in
and out of rehabilitation and sobriety
yes did i get mad yes was i depressed
sometimes yes all of these things are
true
i just didn't physically abuse her and
she's saying none of these things that i
did which are recorded and on the record
are my fault let's go back to her and
see it's a good point what if anything i
think that's what you know you're right
though i mean that is a very good point
i
reached out
to
friends and
family hearsay ask for support objection
hearsay
that's why we had gone back to l.a
johnny was sick
um
after having passed out on the plane so
i took her to dinner
um
we went to benihana's
what
could there be a more high-profile place
because the celebrities i guess i want
to go somewhere quiet where i can relax
and they come to my table and light a
fire yes
i want to share a table with eight
strangers that want to take a photo with
me i feel loved with eight
and they make the choo choo onions it's
almost as funny as the fart machine
shared with brando
wait i left he just laughs way too hard
for way too long
all right let's see by the way you
notice she's saying when they're asking
she's always talking about him
this is something you see she's obsessed
with him
a lot of his questioning was about
himself hers johnny was sick johnny
wanted to do this and i just and then
johnny was this way and i just and she's
always diagnosing him that's interesting
it's a lot of uh
it's not even projections it's just
deflection yeah
all right
it doesn't it's still here say your
honor i'm not crying i'm just gross
may we approach you
is she crying is she crying do you have
to drink is that crying or is that just
sniffles
there's a lot of pollen what's the
pollen index
what's the pollen index i don't have to
keep drinking there's a battery
it's very high okay so then this will
stay
killing me
it's not fair
to get me saused when there's a pollen
lawyer's like may we approach the brand
bench just comes up
spits on
do this right is he laughing
disgusting oh he's laughing
[ __ ]
that's not pollen induced no i don't i
don't know if he was
was he laughing it looked to me i have
[Laughter]
it reminds me of home yes it tickles me
pink
all right since no one has an answer if
he was actually laughing i'll just take
one sip i'm not finishing those
unattractive lawyers
oh he had some pretty foxy lures before
too the guy on the left looks like he's
the before picture before someone gets
teeth he looks like the guy
yeah
he's finally off of alcohol after god
knows how many years and he can fix the
whiskey face
now to 228.
your honor we're going to object on
hearsay son of a [ __ ] first wow
it's sustained every time
i understand
but i think
the sigh
oh when i wore my best funeral frock
oh and i just stole this from a hands
made tail
yes or whatever that's called
handmade or hand man's tail head maiden
and i've watched one episode and i was
like i can't do this no i just saw the
the costumes and i was like no thank you
that's enough
yeah
they're muting it again people will hate
it but it's like game of thrones for me
i've never seen it and i never will
and i don't i know people can get pissed
but it's like i don't
care
about knights and dragons
i don't care it's knights and drag
queens
on game of thrones i don't know i think
there's a lot of people there's a lot of
penis there's a lot of gay i just gave
foreign occasion like i could just watch
the surprise there's about there's about
three good episodes in the entire what
is it eight nine seasons of game of
thrones people act like it's the
greatest show yeah and everything else
is just it's just a tease to get to a
couple of good episodes and the rest of
it is so boring i'm not i'm just i i
could look at it in the commercial for
the original one and i'm like i'll never
watch this show you know what else so
too i think you and i probably share
this you know
being a comedian you like you see an
interview with george r martin you're
like oh that guy has no sense of humor i
probably can't read this right yeah he
takes himself so seriously like if you
go back and you read token like you see
like he actually
talked about this was designed to be
written it was basically meant to be
sort of uh uh you know um the folklore
uh or you said like uh what's the term
like mythology for the western europe
that didn't already exist and uh he said
it was meant for the simple person for
the layman and you seem to have a sense
of humor by himself but george martin
has he has no sense of humor and once
someone shows that i'm like i can't do
it oh no one of the funniest things i've
ever seen too but
is that an episode of family guy and
it's just george r martin's he's just in
his like mobility scooter yeah yeah and
uh
brian walks because he's sitting and he
goes almost always
hey our resident uh psychology phd
candidate uh has some commentary if you
want to bring him in all right okay we
want to bring in our resident uh phd
candidate all right let's bring them on
in yeah yeah yeah
kevin you're such a disease jack and
they're coming back oh okay hold on
they're coming back
so
tell us
if there's an objection i swear to god
what you did then over that night the
next leaf blow pollen all over this room
is that cousin vinny talking at the
hotel
what did you do i cried
a lot
i tried to surround myself with my
friends
and resolve to
leave him
let the records show they're all
imaginary
objection
unresponsive
so she's doing some of the things i was
talking about out there the start stop
is very indicative of somebody that's
lying and kind of fabricating on the
spot so she'll have moments where she
talks
quite a bit and it's just like you
telling a story about your life that
you're
watching the video of in your mind got
my penis caught revolving door once
exactly
that would be a fluid story stop a lot
of people behind it too yeah i know re i
don't know how to be a gentleman in that
do i go first to move the door for the
woman or to let her go first and let the
dope but the problem is there's no way
to be a gentleman when your wiener's
stuck between them
it's just screaming
no that's a good point and i've also
noticed there are very few ums which a
lot of people will say you know in
broadcasting you're not supposed to say
um because it's a word whisker but it's
natural when you're recounting something
as opposed to very staccato articulate
stop
and then this described that way i
notice that's how she's doing it all
right let's see what she's saying half
of mr depp objection hear sounds
did you just call it like a slip and
fall lawyer
like it's unreal well i think whose
objective is who's objecting are johnny
depp's lawyers right now objecting yeah
yeah yeah because her lawyer is
yeah so they're just making it
impossible so it's good for them to do
that but it's exhausting for us
everything a lawyer's doing is like it's
not helping her right content is can you
tell us how did you feel that night
text messages with
amber science
yes objection what's his name
stephen how would you describe your
nipples silver dollar did they take up
most of the breast national geographic
would they be comparable to an ice cream
cone and if so which flavor yes no i'll
allow it i demand it hearsay i'm afraid
that's overruled
why because i'm incredibly horny yes
now pull those out
or i will have you in contempt
and that'll make you pull it out in
court jail
all right oh we got to see this i'm
sorry i don't they just they went back
to the museum
this is the worst all right give us the
your phd candidate give us your break
down here well one of the things that
you see a lot from her is the believe me
phase right and there was a lot of that
in the early parts of her testimony
especially yesterday where she's telling
a story and she's wanting to look at the
jury and she'll kind of go into her
narrative and then
up come the eyebrows don't look me in
the eyes it triggers my aggression
it's true
i see it as a challenge
i'm half drunk and it's 11 central for
god's sakes
because i'm sorry kevin go ahead
analysis is far more valuable than
anything i can contribute here johnny's
all drunk it's like
you believe me right
and she looks to the jury no the
eyebrows come up and then she'll go back
into the start stop right thing and then
she's checking in
because she you know you guys believe me
yeah yeah yeah
which it seems like it's if you're
reliving one of your most and this is
something that people get wrong because
a lot of the body language experts
you'll see on television that person is
looking down and to the left it means
they're lying often if someone is
actually recounting something traumatic
or something that is embarrassing to
them they won't look you in the eye it
doesn't mean that they're lying it means
that they're nervous about it so someone
who looks you in the eye to describe
their most traumatic experience of their
life
that's not natural but because they've
been told be looked them in the eye you
know oh daniel son always look i well no
not if you were raped right you know
longer than three seconds it's getting
weird yes it is yeah you see guys
interact no look at each other in the
eye no listen unless it's a stare down
before a fight they'll talk about
something they did that was like you
know terrible and they'll be like
so do you want to have a appetizer yes
yeah they have fantastic
mineral spirit spinach dip yep
you think you think they'll find the
body
well it's buried under
bags of
burger king refuses
guys of old burger king kids club
friendship bracelets yes
and rings dakota rings
brando eight bags of burgers
scraps they're the best oh it's a vest
oh i felt guilty once because when i was
poor and i was at a hotel on the road i
took a roll because it clearly had been
like it was like one of those places
that would wrap it in foil please been
there yeah
okay i took more than a roll i was
trying i know i took food off of
a take i took food off of room service
trays and i was poor
[Laughter]
well every comic too on earth has been
like this continental breakfast uh also
goes in my pockets
looks like i'm having yogurt and a
banana at five o'clock
and then they're going good and the
other comic walks up and knows exactly
what you're doing and just goes
ruin my
you've ruined dinner
all right what is this a danish oh it
goes in your back pocket i had to go
siphon gas
they're back up on him okay let's hear
amber live
in the days following the plane boston
plane incident
yes i did there were two you tell the
jury about those communications
i
heard from him
directly i also heard from him through
his assistants who were texting for him
objection your honor hearsay i knew i
could meet you
i'm allowed to
testify about the text messages with his
assistant but can you tell the jury
about your communications with mr depp
okay
it's kind of confusing because
he was texting through them objection
your honor i'll sustain the objection
i'll strike that from the record you'll
just regard that testimony oh boy she's
not going to do well with this
yeah just wait for him then you is kevin
can i go before you or do you have to go
first all right you can go and then i'll
go they're breaking her pattern so she's
not able to get on a roll
yeah no that's like that's exactly okay
you did you two talk i want to hear what
she and then i'll come back you guys
update me on all the lies okay roger
about my prediction everything that
brought says is [ __ ] okay right back
we still got all the other room
here okay right away
and he
text me again
that he understood
that i had made my decision to move on
and good luck
transcript helped us out
and then
continued to
contact me
i spoke to him when i was in new york on
the phone and he said that he was
um he had a chip or
that he was going to meetings chocolate
i i think at the time mentioned a sober
uh
another celebrity that was kind of
advising him
on sobriety or not advising him but you
know start stopping encouraging him and
he was saying well look you know me and
this person we're
three days sober four days sober
and that was the last time
the monster will never come back monster
will never she's telling the story
that is kind of weird it felt so much
worse than it had ever been before
it is strange it's like
kevin would you say she's performing for
the jury
definitely well and
the point about um's and uh the thought
linkers that i'm doing right now myself
i think is well made but we are talking
about an actress here who right a lot of
time in front of camera has spent their
whole time doing interviews so we might
actually be seeing who she is now
without the thought lingers like that
she just might be that good
right which makes the start stop thing
so like pronounced i've seen her back
down
you've seen one i said i've seen them
back down she's not that good no yeah
that's a good point
your emotions and
how you felt about all this objection
hearsay
okay
well let's go also lay the foundation
your honor let's go to the defenders
good gravy
like shouldn't she be answering the
lawyer and not staring off to the side i
mean tim makes a good point like this
yeah that does like that's someone asks
you a question
you look at them yeah you start looking
at them and then she just looks off and
answers the same as we just looked at
each other for that point of
conversation yeah as opposed to me
staring at everyone else to see what
they thought you know it's insane it's
like so dave um i i agree with what you
say yeah yeah that's yeah i'm just gonna
look everywhere else is the jury are you
believing my [ __ ] all right great
well that's what i associated gross
groups would do that a lot during the
trial who wouldn't gage gross grits when
he was also a domestic abuser
and uh you know oh that idiot from
and then look over riots be like you
guys believe me right yeah yeah and then
turn right and then very informative it
is very weird the guy who drove farther
than kyle with a gun yes exactly yeah if
they don't get a pattern here we'll go
to mud club and take chat because this
is just this is it's just death oh
there's a pattern it just sounds like a
that she can never they can never answer
which means that his attorneys are doing
a good job oh he is not this is why when
you watch shows like boston legal or the
practice you realize that it's it's not
like that in real life it's very tedious
well kevin and tim have both pointed out
like she's kind of performing to the
jury her face always goes to them she's
kind of asking it out she's not really
answering the questions it's more of a
performance every time and that's why i
think she's
constantly getting here to say here also
she slept with half of them well of
course it's just james franco oh that
looks like a cry listen i'm going to
give you fair judgment
i don't want to cry i'm willing i'm
willing to serve my community sit on the
jury all right let's see uh
oh god embarrassed and sorry he said he
was and i believed him
and this is a four percent beer it's
basically water
[Laughter]
all right
didn't come back with him
all right i'm gonna go because i don't
care
okay we'll come back a chat
uphold his promise
to do the treatment to do the full detox
clean up and never go back
[Music]
again she's talking about johnny what
johnny needed to go to rehab johnny
didn't do the detox johnny didn't do
this what about you amber what about you
that's that's what i think people are
picking up on i don't know you guys can
comment below and i would love to see
your comments because a lot it is
interesting to see this dynamic of
specifically women specifically women
who've been abused but
across the board uh
not by it and i think the big reason
that people are turned off is johnny
depp did answer questions about himself
about his inner demons about his flaws
and she
is focused on questions about him
about his flaws
and for the same reason that people
don't like a tattletail it's like okay
but
what about you and she hasn't gotten to
that you just want to talk about that
this
doctor was gonna be the solution the
cure you know uh
and he got he got brought on board and
all this stuff doctor was robert smith
that this
team would be involved in johnny's
recovery
so it felt real felt serious i felt like
protected you know it already by this
point heard a million times it seems
like a promise is to get clean and sober
but this felt like
a change
and they were going to come to boston
and start working with johnny plan was
to keep
johnny
on on the same level
of drugs that he was on since he was
filming they needed him to finish
filming
the movie uh so he was going to be
maintained
with his um
with prescription pills including the
painkillers
and
the the
the plan was he would obviously abstain
from alcohol completely and all other
drugs like weed and coke
and then when he finished for someone
here's also something for someone who's
so concerned
about and i would say obsessed with
johnny depp's substance abuse issues
it really is weird that she was going
because they were only married for was
it a year a little more than a year
it wasn't a very long amount of time
maybe it was 15 months at most was 15
months you know yesterday she talked
about
three separate instances when she was
doing drugs with johnny depp mdma when
they went to this trailer park uh mdma
on the plane so for someone who's like i
just really wanted to get off drugs and
get sober but you were doing drugs with
him so when did you start taking it
seriously
hmm
right yeah 15 months 15 months you're
right
without saying what the communications
were and if that's the case does she
take responsibility for enabling him
uh where johnny was i just would come
for short periods of time
in between i mean on weekends from
filming until i wrapped my movie which i
did yeah
i think whoever wrote this drinking game
needs to be on temporary leave
well they nailed it it's a good case
they're going to kill me
debbie lloyd
at least every time she does believe me
face isn't in the drinking game there
would just be alcohol yes exactly just
i'll be in the hospital
medications which they shared with me
told me about objection your honor
hearsay
[Music]
but we have to be careful about what
other people told you
okay so you can testify yes uh please
refrain from see we're in a courtroom so
being a gossipy high school [ __ ]
doesn't quite apply here
this doesn't meet the minimum threshold
for the court
i know the amount that johnny told them
he was
on was
so that they
they could maintain him for the filming
meaning not make a drastic change in the
amount that wasn't
no when it wasn't her film it was his
film
we just have a movie mentioned his
behavior his whole personality changed
drastically
he
would be did it change when you gave him
mdma twice time i was staying in boston
with him having wrapped my movie and he
would in mid mid-sentence he just she
just said my movie
[Music]
one time i was getting across from him
and i'm not gonna give that away the
good thing is i can finish so someone
else needs to bring me a drink because
this is almost done so it's a perfect
time for me to have to completely what
appeared to be asleep while talking to
me and he had a cigarette in his hand
and you know johnny constantly smoked
and he just obsessed with him cigarettes
johnny smoked johnny this johnny that
see like this is probably true yeah
there's no break in the pattern and it
sounds like an episodic memory
um
and and he smells like virginia slims
[Laughter]
i understand it he definitely looks like
he smells like virginians
with
drug use um
in my family i imagine being johnny
depp's acupuncturist
[Laughter]
trying to figure out with the nurses
masseuse
can you just shower
the change and what medications were
causing it hazmat suit i knew there were
new medications involved so
you know i was constantly um
worried and in communication
and johnny's behavior got worse and
worse johnny johnny johnny johnny johnny
johnny johnny
waking up in the middle of the night
screaming waking up in the middle of the
night sometimes crying
and the emotions would change from one
to the next like by the by the second he
would the
[Music]
i remember
you on the stand right now
you know i mean it's pretty tough to
argue that the man is not a narcissist
who wears more super bowl rings than the
chicago bears
i really didn't know
um i felt so bad for him and i i thought
maybe it was just what kipper had
introduced into the regime the
medications
but you just see him reach down and bite
a piece of candy off his bracelet
this has all been one big giant
commercial for ring pop yeah i knew it
big ring pop just stuff the fun don't
stop ring pop i also have a cheerio
necklace depending on if i want candy or
something healthy
when he started shows edibles
with the doctors so
how is he getting away with sunglasses
they've got to be transition lenses or
something
you just laughed [ __ ] i'm not fit this
is a new drink i'm not finishing this
drink
i'm not finishing this drink sometimes i
didn't expect him to laugh this much
because i'm not finishing this
that weeks months
it was so agonizing i don't know how
long that's something that seems very
fake when someone says days weeks months
eons
it seemed endless
it was so agonizing
was it
right no
not really
if something was agonizing for months
you'd surely notice
[Laughter]
but something that was happening
yesterday in her testimony she was
bouncing around between tenses wait she
was bouncing can we get do we even
jump up and down or again i would it
would be have you been condemned
objection overruled
were you saying there no it was like he
slapped but then
slap and there was this change of tense
in when the verbs were happening and
yeah
that's also indicative of fabrication as
opposed to just yeah he went outside and
then he did this and then he did that or
something like that right now you have a
so you have a master's in psychology is
that it and then you're a phd candidate
yes okay yes finishing the dissertation
as we speak okay so we'll probably need
to find his replacement because he's
going to go psychoanalyze people
otherwise that's just wasted talent here
he practiced on me
yeah well no urinating on you that's not
a part of i know i was like are you sure
you're a doctor he goes no i'm not a
doctor right you're like you told me
this was immersion therapy and you said
i did yes and i said i don't
self-describe as a psychologist yet
totally fine
you're in therapy that's right that
doesn't make sense
take it well that's great i love how the
camera behind johnny just moved up to
the cleavage behind him
[Laughter]
there's some guy right now he's like
there's no there's no way c spans on my
camera
the director's like camera two stop with
the tits count of two stop i'll never
stop
seriously
we're not telling you again go a little
closer next time
[Applause]
a little bit closer now a little bit
closer now let's see them tears now
let's see i'm gonna tear this now this
is all perverts on camera you just see
breasts
she knows
all right boobs are huge
can you please describe for the jury
well there's that compilation of him and
her interacting that i said
oh okay well let's let's
when there's the next break we'll watch
that and then take chat at mud club
first few days
okay
peaceful i
the nurse
uh and then later nurse and doctor we're
staying on a different part of the
island um
about the next few minutes drive
by atvs
in 15 minutes it was a guy
one of those atv doctor was a girl but
we
communicated to be alive occasionally
through texts and
you don't have a hand
and then the behavior
that it just really wasn't okay
it was
up
down he'd be mad at me
then he was wanting a hug
he cried
a lot and then he
um
which is weird which is weird you know
wanted to have sex a lot like which is
what oh what
someone who's married to
this would want to have sex often
that's unheard of so weird so bizarre is
that an appeal to sexism
yeah yeah that's a drink i mean it's
appealing sex
i think i'm coming up with a diagnosis
yeah he wanted to have someone company
all the time which is largely the reason
he married me
psychiatrist runs in like he's
disrupting a wedding it for you know
speaking of forever hold your peace
objection that's a frigid [ __ ]
you know the i guess the effect
on that did you need to change what'd
you do to him did you let him did you
how many times a week yeah
because if it's under four i'm going to
hold you in criminal contempt are you a
missionary or do you like to get weird
like a man crying
how many hammocks do you own yeah
would you like swings
he screamed at me about that tried to
overturn this table
luckily it was like jesus
you just portrayed johnny depp as jesus
good work amber
did you say welded down
sweet
and
thanking me and
he does seem like a guy who has like a 5
000 pound table made of wood that
doesn't even exist anymore right
like it was taken from the redwoods yeah
did she just say that she he thanked her
after sex
i don't think humanity well i mean i
would imagine yeah i would
like high five good game yeah
thanks again
i'm gonna give you an ecto cooler and uh
chocolate bar
no please don't poop on the
i saved his bedspread and he wouldn't be
doing this without me
i was telling him these things and i was
at one point in our conversations i told
him about how objection your honor
hearsay
[Music]
please try to continue without what you
said please
um
i said something to him
[Music]
no more there can't be any more
objection
[Laughter]
but he did it like crying
so what was the weirdest thing
you never ever know when you have too
much of something that tastes bad but
then you have more of it
and then it tastes good again pretty
good that's a good thing it's like amber
that's where i am
objects
[Laughter]
but you know didn't want to make him
feel embarrassed
i
[Laughter]
is
[Laughter]
he's an unbelievable actor
i forgot that scene exists until i
showed it to my son a couple years ago
yeah i was like oh i forgot about this
really sad drunk he's my favorite
japanese actor named pat yes by far
screaming at me also
arnold was it arnold pat
morita there's another or his name is
pat moreta yeah all right i want to see
if she's crying let's go outside mug
club and find out his name chances are
it's not even the same guy
[Laughter]
he was um
accusing me of having
a man in the house with me oh where
could he ever get that idea again
you know in a cabin it's basically one
room with a closet and a bathroom in an
elevator with james franco in this hide
really i mean there's a closet and a
bathroom
and he at one point in a tesla with elon
musk in it i was hiding somebody in the
house
another point he was communicating with
someone not in the room
this sounds like she's trying to
describe psychosis
that she read from a textbook which by
the way has never been presented
anywhere else you know that's when we
were talking about the mmpi two tests
yeah and uh and you can take it on you
can take it online you can at least look
at some of the questions because i know
that that was where her uh oh sorry the
psychologist said that she
uh was lying through the test and i was
curious about this and there are
questions like that exactly right do you
speak to people in the room who aren't
there right do you see so it sounds to
me like she read through a psychological
textbook and she's trying to ascribe
that to him whereas these are never
concerned she brought up before that
before now right no and the mmpi is good
in that regard i mean i don't want to
give away all the secrets but uh the
questions on there are critical items
that'll that nobody responds to
correctly but if they're trying to sound
crazy they will like right sometimes i
see in black and white
yeah no you don't well and also
is it really that when he's going hey is
the guy who was banging my wife still
here yeah he's not talking to no one
he's trying to find someone in this
house he's like he's like elon uncle
frank
james
buzz
they make for a fun conversation though
clinically like i've had clients and you
go over the test with them and you'd be
like so
sometimes you see black and white say
more like oh i'm a racist okay well that
was a misinterpretation of right wow
that was weird all right let's see what
she see two colors yes
[Laughter]
the process of detox in la
and i had my friends out
with my girlfriends there to support me
as per usual
so let's michelle can you pull up two
seven two please detox in la is a girl's
night
i'm just showing up with like
bachelorette party it was like penis
lollipops yeah detox
night
per usual
there's eating
[Laughter]
johnny's really been [ __ ] the bed
lately yeah oh i really didn't mean to
poop is but i think it was maybe the
corn cob pipe that i ate i don't know
let's drink turpentine and ruin some
sheets
can we redact that oh redacted message
man what color is your hair
i don't know anymore
do you and johnny share the same
five color hair dye
no thank you well no no he uses just for
men and i use just for [ __ ]
actually it's mostly for [ __ ]
and this is on forgot six i only got
seven million dollars out of 14
text message from sorry after i gave to
charity
seven million dollars out of this yes
right
okay
just to let you know i'm fine my angel i
miss you of course but this was the
right thing to do to speed up the
process i love you more than life yours
steve
steve this is sent to amber heard all
right let's see what she says
yours steve you see that
i do
so
what if any expressions was mr depp
giving you at this point that he was
angry with you ever uh
having to help participate with the
detox or to be on the island or anything
along that line objection form compound
i'll allow it but just i would have
objected that was definitely a
compounding question
too has already been entered into
evidence without that reactions and
there wasn't any objection so i would
wish if i could have both sides to keep
track of their evidence it's not my
job to keep
this also i object to johnny depp's
representation silly barber poultier
it's really the party's responsibility
to take care of the record not mine my
apologies on that one your honor
she really does have dead's eyes like
the doll line oh she does yeah
and when she comes for half your [ __ ]
and those eyes
no legal notification of papers had been
sent
she writes her article on huffpo
sometimes gold digging horror goes away
sometimes you stay sometimes go looking
away oh we got another one sometimes
gold digging [ __ ] gives you
mdma and looks under your soul
let's see what this text is
her response hallucinating and angry at
me at various moments and she said i
can't live without you you are my
everything there are no words fake fake
fake fact i just want you to be okay and
happy i love you more every single day
can't imagine my life without you hey by
the way that kind of gets to uh the
abuse of don't leave don't leave don't
leave when someone is abusive they try
and make it so that you cannot leave
that's a big thing right
and
it's often combined with them leaving
temporarily and coming back so they put
you on your heels and you fear being
abandoned while they make you know that
if you abandon them they could kill
themselves they could right they want to
put they want to put the responsibility
of of you on you and the responsibility
of them on you and that's what she's
doing
i'm not a i'm not a psychologist no
that's
definitely on to something and then
there's also
the pattern disruption that she would
engage in
of like don't go don't go don't go okay
that breaks him from what he wants to do
then the little thing in your mind the
periaqueductal gray matter to geek out
for a second
makes you notice when your freedom's
being inhibited right and then anger
starts to come up but then if that anger
starts to come out
then oh no we can't talk right now right
and yeah that makes and then she puts on
she dressed like she dresses like samuel
adams
i
bargained
with him
about me doing the role and he told me
uh drink that's her mentioning her role
in a movie oh gosh
well the most
the only role i'm concerned with is the
lack of them you were taking in the
hazel
[Music]
don't say what you said just say what he
said okay
i'm not finishing any more drinks i
don't care what the rules are he
reluctantly kind of agreed
to me working
on this movie or reaching your job
in london at the time
i
enjoy your weekend
[Laughter]
i wore no makeup or minimal makeup in
the movie
no sexy clothing she just talked about
how good looking she is like i just i
did everything i could to not make
myself attractive and you know it's a
lost cause yeah so
i was like no makeup and they looked and
they said i thought you were wearing all
the makeup
and i didn't wear any revealing clothing
and they said sweetheart
you'd be gorgeous if you wore a tarp and
i said no no
i said no
is it even if you dress like shakespeare
on the witness stand
i was there for my last like day or two
take the skull
she's holding it the whole
need like a humble brag counter
ask you to turn to not even like humble
bragging this is bragging dragon
oh she just looked like she was confused
a little bit like maybe she was
surprised by something uh like 3 10. i
can't count that far yeah do you have
communications with
princesses
oh she is getting ragdolled
she is getting ragdolls she just can't
get a rhythm going i think they saw what
happened yesterday where she was going
up you know these soliloquies which was
like and then and then you realize and
this and they just decided that if she
can't do that
she has no sort of factual leg to stand
on so let's make her
have to stick to the facts
so it's a pretty good contrast to show
when she can talk and she can opine
which people saw yesterday and they felt
like they were being manipulated and
then today it's a good strategy for the
attorney to say let's make sure now that
there's no hearsay allowed there's no uh
you know painting it with the brush of
your point of view let's stick to what
is allowable what is admissible and she
can't do it this is really bad for her
and while that's being redacted and i
still don't think he's going to win the
defamation
i agree but i think he's won
saying to you in this time frame we're
talking in november if he does you just
donate the money to wherever she said
she was going to yeah we're not taking
on any more or donate it to like the
opposing charity yeah like if she was
gonna donate to peta donate it to like
the seal killing foundation yeah that's
the opposing charity for a children's
hospital though well she said aclu and
then children's hospital i don't know
like it's a hospital for the elderly
yeah instead of battered housewives he
just sends it to batter housewives yeah
the gillian maxwell legal fund
[Laughter]
to work on and
he was furious at me for he found
like we call them sides they're just
pieces of an audition pages all right
you know what guys i can't do this i'm
going to be drunk let's uh look we're
going to see you are we thursday let's
just get you doing a job
[Laughter]
you're going to be in like in
lincoln yeah yep
lincoln missouri something like that
yeah lincoln nebraska where are you
going to be lincoln nebraska and uh
springfield missouri this is springfield
missouri there's a burger king there
right here oh we'll just throw it over
the fence marlin brandon when you're
done with it take what you want you just
give me what you don't want to throw it
over the fence
and then i'm gonna be in spokane i don't
know somewhere in july it's a secret
show we don't have it on the website
because
are you gonna take your chat
make him piss off youtube
[Music]